to Iran now where Security forces have
made dozens more arrests as
anti-government demonstrations enter a
six-week rights campaigners say the
protesters are putting their lives at
risk the death of a young woman held by
the so-called morality police set off
the first unrest growing into a
nationwide protest movement a brutal
Crackdown by the Iranian authorities has
not stopped hundreds of thousands of
people taking to the streets
[Music]
once again Iran's young women took the
lead removing their headscarves chanting
anti-government slogans and facing off
against the security forces a sixth week
of Nationwide protests sparked by the
death and custody of Masa amini
the protests began with demonstrations
against the mandatory hijab
but they've grown into the greatest
challenge to the Islamic Republic since
the 2009 green movement over disputed
elections
shopkeepers students and Factory workers
are showing their support for the
Nationwide protests
security forces have responded with
violence firing live rounds and
dispersing Gatherings with tear gas
campaigners say more than 200 people
have been killed
public anger about masamini's death has
gone Global from Tokyo to Berlin
in the German Capital eighty thousand
people joined a rally in solidarity
Marchers led by a women's group made
their way through the city in the Autumn
Sun
the leaders of the Free World to hear
the voice of Iranian people they asked
for their ambassadors to leave that
criminal government not to negotiate
with that criminal government and to
help Iranian people to be able to be
able to choose the kind of leaders and
governments and life they want to live
I'm amazed it's the first time that our
Nations that so many people in our
nations are
um
United
regardless of their political beliefs
before Revolution and after revolution
and yeah so I'm really proud to be here
today
waving flags and holding signs
criticizing Iran's clerical rulers they
chanted women life freedom
[Applause]
we'd like to bring in now Negan shirakai
an activists for women's rights she
joins us now from London it's nice to
have you with us this weekend 80 000
people have been out on the streets of
Berlin do demonstrations outside Iran
make a difference for the people in the
country
in my view definitely and I think in
your report you kind of assign to those
things two Iranians talked about it at
one level the Iranian and the Islamic
Republic Government tried for 40 days 40
years to say that there is no Unity
outside Iran there is no real opposition
there is no alternative for us so if we
go it would be Iran would become like
Iraq or on a stable like Syria so you
have to deal with us you have to try and
reform within and stay with us this
demonstration shows that there is that
Unity outside Iran maybe for the first
time in years but it's it's a massive
Unity that people would drive and take
trains for hours to get to Berlin from
across Europe to show their solidarity
with the Iranians inside and and ask the
governments of Europe for to for for a
thing that is another level something
that the Iranian demonstration
demonstrators inside Iran are asking for
it's that the legitimacy of this
government is not accepted by the people
inside Iran and it shouldn't be accepted
by Foreign governments we know like in
in years before
um I'll be quick about this that that
the governments have been dealing with
the with the Iranian government in a way
that's saying like we've got to give you
some money and we know those money went
to buying Crackdown and civilians
equipment and that's why they shouldn't
do anything else with with Iran yeah you
know it Bears repeating live rounds have
been fired at protesters reports of 200
killed how has violence from authorities
against protesters affected the spirit
of the demonstration as far as you can
see
right now that when we are talking there
are School teachers across the country
are going on a strike they're going to a
school but they're not teaching at the
classes and this is the protest against
a brutal killing of a school girl inside
a school in RWBY last week so there is a
Crackdown there is a brutal uh killing
of people as you mentioned but people
feeling they have to react to it there's
an anger inside the country that is
boiling and takes people to their
streets and in my view it would continue
for a while at at least I didn't expect
it to continue for six weeks but they're
Brave they're still continuing it but
there is a need for another thing that
hopefully we will from outside we would
create it and that's a dream that's a
dream of how it would look like if this
uh government would go away and then
what we will have in instead of that
we'll have to end it there that is a
Nadine many many thanks